90% of the clothes they're not gonna fit
my small frame is not what doors think
of the other size 15 they've no scaring
away normal customers dialing in on what
actually fits you is more important than
just getting something that gives you
the look I actually try my best to go to
source that have extra smalls available
because those usually fit me very well I
think I feel the most conscious of
myself at formal events because formal
events involve Blazers the shoulders
don't quite sit right on my body and
anything that goes past my waist will
make me look shorter than I already am
so one physical characteristic that
people will come up to you and just like
throw in your face about you boy are you
tall most stores don't have anything for
me so my go-to clothing is usually like
solid colored t-shirts like I need a
very long t-shirt but that usually makes
it wider I just sort of gave up as a
bigger dude I'm totally comfortable in
the size of my body but you don't want
to look unflattering plain and simple
typically like I will wear my pants a
little higher just to kind of like
flatten out the stomach and if I can't
find clothes that don't look good on me
then it makes me really not want to go
shopping I think this is gonna be super
fun I'm gonna get man's forum today what
would you consider an area of
opportunity in your wardrobe there's a
lot of real estate
I want to accentuate the right areas of
my torso for me like part of looking
sharp is to have form-fitting stuff one
of my concerns when I wear tighter
fitting clothing is mobility
I won't even wear these shoes all that
often because they've got laces like my
feet are so far away from my head you'd
actually have a greater closet if you
remove things that are either eyesores
that you don't gravitate towards things
that are ill fitting or things that are
pretty old and tattered yeah these jeans
a big hole in them we all have different
body shapes and when I wanted to let the
guys know today is that what you feel is
your insecurity is usually your strength
let's see a new look oh yeah I love it
notice that clipped a few of the areas
to show you that you should generally go
for this fit you take the clips out here
and the only alteration that should
actually need is a hint the most basic
alteration you can get from either
tailor or dry cleaners or him is
probably about five to ten bucks
tailoring is an option and I think a lot
of us especially guys they forget that
I'm feeling myself this is so nice oh my
god haha wow I've never seen myself look
like this before in my life yeah it
didn't know his sizes and I wanted to
help him feel like he knows the things
that fit in and how to be assertive when
going shopping as easy as just like
understanding your measurements and like
what's going to work for you that's the
hurdle that I cleared today oh my god we
spend so much money going shopping this
weekend
turn around oh-ho this is what I'm
talking about his body type as many
others needs to be seen first as the
shape that he'd like to see thinking
about your ensemble in a silhouette
you're then able to see the broader
picture first thing you see is that
person shape and then start filling in
the pieces adding accent it is a softer
shoulder jacket I got a little bit more
move around I'm still just like looking
at myself like is that me so for all the
big dudes that think that they can't
have style look at this you know that
fear of being tall and not thinking
anything is gonna be for you just takes
like finding a couple examples of it to
then be able to know what you're looking
for when you're a smaller guy it's not
about dressing taller it's about
distressing better figure self what you
tease should be for you and not for
whatever's trending
first your personality close second you
can go out and find clothing that it
fits you be looks good C is comfortable
and D makes you look confident as hell